oh genes control my life oh
i am a victim of my genes so whatever
happens to me and i have nothing to do
with it the genes they go bad program
because epigenetics is the new program
that says no
your consciousness is adjusting your
genes you want to change your life
change your consciousness the moment you
change your consciousness you can create
a whole new life we need to create a
conscious planet that's what we're
striving for now to create a more
conscious planet if you are conscious
you have evolved
out of your monkeyness quite some time
ago
how do i empower the self so it's not in
the state where it's grasping you know
how do i sit with my emotions to allow
myself to understand that the way that
it feels makes sense and it all of this
process causes a calming down of in the
integration of the ego and so what we
end up with eventually is the conscious
ego which most people don't
understand as a state that exists most
people think consciousness is when you
get rid of the ego i think it's the
worst thing we've ever taught honestly
wow like we're trying to progress to a
place where
the conscious ego is a choice self-foot
is a choice so
the whole concept of self is something
which you can put on and you can take
off and you can choose elements of and
you can extract from and it's this
relationship to the selfhood that is
very much like it's not something that
stuck to me so to say i am me and that's
some special spiritual entity as far as
i can tell it's electrochemical synapses
firing in your brain got it so it's
giving you this
belief that you are something other than
just the chemistry and biophysics a
brain matter what is making it fire like
what what is the what is the um what is
asking it to do something what makes me
think to ask you a question
this is consciousness and this is a huge
frontier
now here's something i'm going to tell
you no one else is going to tell you you
ready
for sure if everybody's
writing books on a subject
it means we know nothing about it
the more literature there is makes sense
the less we know about it that's why
people keep writing go
go to the books if there's still
bookstores go to the bookstore
look at the shelf on the human mind oh
there's shelf after shelf after show now
look at the shelf of physics
there's the gravity book
and that's it it's like it's that it's
because what because it is what it is it
is what it is we're there we're on to
the next thing we got this
so the fact that everyone and their
cousin
is writing a book on consciousness is
evidence of what we do not yet know i'm
just saying so are you saying that this
is the exciting little frontier spot
where we're at yes
consciousness what do you think about
consciousness i think about it all the
time
and i'm with you with you here's how i
think about it
it's
why do i wake up every morning
as me so that means everything that we
create in the world out there
is telling us something about ourselves
in here this it's a it's a mind blower
it's a really interesting way of
thinking so all the art
all the sculptures all the music i'm a
musician when i'm when i'm not being an
author all the music that we create
uh the movies hollywood
look at the films
that people are most drawn true to the
blockbusters
and and look at the themes of those
films the matrix for example
told us that there's a world that we
can't see
that we participate in that influences a
world that we can see
the movie avatar
reminded us of our relationship to to
nature in the natural world inception
was all about dreams and dreams within
dreams
and the young people i i love this young
people are so
turned on man they are fired up over the
superheroes the avengers and wonder
woman
all
reminding them that there is a potential
within them
that maybe
they have yet to fully tap that we have
abilities that we're only beginning to
understand so
if consciousness informs itself
through its creations
then that principle would extend to the
technology
so i am not surprised
that the internet that we built
mimics our neural networks within our
bodies
this is such a powerful principle
consciousness
informs itself through its creations
it's probably the deepest experiences
i've ever had with meditation
that i can share of that genuine feeling
that i'm not my body and this is just a
container and a vessel in a vehicle
and that i'm a consciousness beyond this
and so are you and so is everyone else
because we have a program that's called
the biological imperative it's built
into every organism from bacteria all
the way up to humans i say what what is
that imperative
the drive to survive
a bacterium is built with a biological
imperative if you try and kill it it's
not going to go oh okay kill me no the
bacterium will do every maneuver
possible to stay alive so we are built
to survive well to be able to survive
you better be careful of things that
threaten you
so things that threaten you take more
interest
because i gotta be uh these things could
threaten me so i look at the scary
things i didn't look at the good things
i'm okay with them i got no problem with
that it's the things that scare me that
i pay more attention to and i go
consciousness is creating your reality
if you put a picture of fear
into your reality then your biology
behavior will manifest things to be
afraid of because
this is a short statement but to me it's
the most powerful one simple and short
it goes like this
the function of the mind
is to create coherence between your
beliefs
and your reality
if i have a negative belief the function
of my mind is to manifest behavior to
experience those negative realities
if i have positive beliefs then the
function of my mind is to manifest the
positive experience
but we get programmed with so many
negative beliefs
and that takes our wire power because
we're not focusing on the beautiful
things we're focusing on the fear what
are you afraid of like uh people can't
keep their phone aside now because like
this like this because it's got some
thousand gb of some nonsense all right
going on
if you just keep it aside and switch it
off
you can sit here it's over
right but they can't do it
because they have no means they've never
seen how
because it is not about the phone
it is because you're compulsive it may
be your phone it may be a cigarette
maybe a drink it may be a food it may be
a person
you can't keep your hands free because
you're compulsive
it may be your
longing for food or pleasure or
something but essentially you're
compulsive
if you're compulsive
you kind of denying your evolutionary
status
because the significance of being human
is we can be conscious
we not doing anything very different
from what the other creatures are doing
they are also just born like us
you know their parents came together
they were born our parents came together
we were born
we grow up
they grow up very easily we grow up with
lot of fuss
then what is the next significant thing
that you do as a generation if you look
next thing is maybe we will reproduce
and they will reproduce without fuss you
will be produced with a lot of fuss and
one day you will die that also with a
lot of us they do it more gracefully
so everything that you do every and to
elephant everybody is doing it
only thing is we can do it consciously
this is a massive
difference that we can do the same
simple things consciously suddenly it's
another space suddenly it's a completely
different possibility if you do not
exercise
this ability to be conscious
in every act that you are because
consciousness is not in the act that you
perform right now i hear that
everybody's saying be mindful of this my
be mindful of that
mindfulness will make you a little more
alert maybe you'll survive better than
others okay but consciousness
is your existence
so you know you're here only because
you're conscious isn't it
if you fall asleep and you're
unconscious you don't know where you're
sitting because if everything's just
fractal in nature and it's just sort of
perfect geometry happening all over the
place it
i'm wondering where consciousness plays
into it and our existence and what we're
essentially here for
why are we even able to quantify or
question this
because source itself is trying to know
itself
and i i think this is one of the most
freeing answers
if people really understand it but it's
also a terrifying answer it's like you
know that there's a terror in freedom
and there's a terror in responsibility
and there's a terror for humans if they
start looking at this concept of source
or god as if it's not this all-knowing
being that already has everything
planned out
when p when humans understand that
source itself has a subconscious
and does not know itself
it's like oh no we're out on a limb but
it gets even scarier when i tell you
that every creature that has ever been
you know created in existence
you know it sources all there is so it's
essentially taking parts of itself and
like let's see all of the potentials of
me so as to become self-aware so we are
facilitating self-awareness within
source itself yeah so a good example
from other experiences often we would
meditate in
extreme cold or heat
and and the purpose of that was to
when you're in that much physical pain
you have no choice but to go inward
and so it's almost like you enter into
the inner world and the inner universe
of the the connectedness between
everything so you're no longer feeling
the physical connection with the body
like right now i'm sitting i can feel
that i'm sitting yeah and i can feel
that my leg you know i've crossed my
legs because i've always feel
comfortable when i cross my legs on
chairs than sitting with my legs down
and so but i can feel that i'm doing
that i'm conscious of it whereas my
point is losing that physical
consciousness of yourself
and to not feel like you're even sitting
here to not feel like you're in this
physical space
to really experience that has probably
been one of my favorite experiences of
meditation and i don't try and and the
goal isn't to feel that like that's not
right that's where people get confused
like i don't meditate to feel that
when you meditate purely and deeply you
experience that as a byproduct and so
it was very very clearly explained to us
that you're not meditating to be
powerful or gain powers or gain
these mystic abilities that's not the
point like you meditate to build up the
deepest connection with yourself and
others in the universe and a byproduct
of that is that you may experience this
i'm me
what makes that that right and consider
that identical twins with identical dna
have separate consciousness
consciousnesses
separate they're not the same people
they have different thoughts
they might have similar desires or you
know they have twins separated and they
will drive the same color car or
whatever with as they later discover
that happens
fine but i'm talking about
are you hungry in this moment
that's your consciousness telling you
that and your twin just ate an hour ago
your twin is not having that same
thought
this is the big challenge with the with
the transporter in star trek
if i disassemble your molecules and
reassemble them over there
is your consciousness part of that
is your consciousness even a
transferable entity right
i don't know
so and let me ask a more blunt question
is consciousness even the right question
to ask
we think it's the right question
so the question now that scientists are
asking
uh this is where the the really intense
podcast gets really really intense it's
called the forbidden question
the forbidden question is
are we living in what is called a base
reality
or are we living in a virtual
reality or a simulated reality that is
reflecting
a base reality somewhere else
now a lot of people think you know well
this is science fiction
if consciousness informs itself through
its creations and we have made all of
these movies
about these simulations what are we
asking ourselves to remember
right now you're conscious
question is only how conscious so now
all you need to do is turn up the
voltage because you cannot be conscious
without generating an intense level of
energy have you noticed when you're on
full throttle
and taking the corner you far more
conscious than sitting on a chair
yes yes now
let me translate that that is not the
way it should be because that is still
alertness
but there is an element of consciousness
in that
suppose you could keep yourself like
that
without the necessary
adrenaline attached to it
without the necessary maybe an element
of fear or danger attached to it if you
could simply sit like here
keeping your blood pressure down
but
as alert as you were taking that corner
at full speed
then you will achieve something that you
have never imagined possible
you will hit a pitch of life that you
never imagined possible if you
understand the process
you can rewrite your life
and change the outcome you can change
these programs sometimes in 15 minutes
or less okay but you need to know how to
do it okay
the relevance about all this is um
uh
the movie the matrix
uh is oh science fiction i go no no no
movie the matrix is a documentary what
do you mean i go premise everybody's
been programming go oh that's a given
we are all programmed from last
trimester to age seven everyone is
but in the movie they say well you can
take a red pill and get out of the
program and i want to suggest that most
people in our audience right now that we
have here today have taken the red pill
at one time or another and their life
profoundly changed like when was that
one of the best examples is when people
fall in love like what do you mean i go
well their life is blah blah blah blah
blah they fall in love they meet
somebody 24 hours later
oh life is so beautiful i'm so in love
i'm so happy look i'm glowing look i got
growth hormone in my system
i go
24 hours later after blah blah blah all
those years and 24 hours later you
manifest heaven on earth i go
how'd that happen and the answer is
beautiful
because the answer is when you fall in
love you stop thinking
you stay present it's called staying
mindful like what does that mean i say
when you're thinking is when the
subconscious
autopilot kicks in
if you're not thinking then the
conscious creative mind is the one
that's manifesting your life so
the moment you fell in love why would
you think and the reason is this you've
been waiting for this person your whole
life they showed up you want to think
and disconnect from this i go no you
want to stay present you want to be
mindful you want to be there i go you
stop thinking i say what's the result
it's the red pill
the moment you stop thinking is you're
not diverting to the subconscious
anymore you are operating from conscious
wishes and desires and so the honeymoon
is not an accident it's a manifestation
that says i'm not playing a program
actually you have not enjoyed the power
of stillness
that's why you think this is
this is better amphetamine is better
than being
still
stillness is the nature of the existence
over 99 percent of the existence
which is not material in nature in this
entire cosmos right not even one percent
is material existence rest is all
absolutely still
this is the lap of creation
you must be there always because you're
a piece of creation you are best only
when you're in the lap of creation
[Music]